- Amigos un preguntita.
Estos son Reeboks o son Nikes?
- Son Nikes.
- Oh yeah.
(spanish guitar)
- Billy Jean is not my lover.
She's just a girl who
said that I am the one,
- Tu quires manzana.
- Cuz I'm free,
Frijoles.
- Sin jeans al medioda.
Who am I to disagree?
- Try to try to swim again.
Vomitando por nariz.
Oh I beg, I beg and plead.
- It's too late, tonight.
Te traigo pasta
into the light.
- It's getting late but I don't mind.
Es que de ley voy a tomar.
- I think it might just
work out fine this time.
- All right. Pinguino Rodriguez.
- I think it might just work out fine.
- Et es en mudder, who's run right.
Transpiren. Transpiren.
Transpiren, Transpiren.
- Lucho sabe ingles.
Lucho sabe ingles.
Yeah. Yeah.
- Lucho sabe ingles.
(speaks in Spanish)
- I hate this pocket. It's so
hard to get stuff out of here.
Yeah, but it's (inaudible). Fuck!
- Oh shit!
- I know how to make her come.
- They're too sweaty.
(people laugh)